por qué
[Música]
diez años de prisión fue la sentencia
que recibió la ex presidenta interina de
bolivia jeanine áñez luego de que fuera
acusada de ocupar la presidencia de ese
país suramericano
aparentemente de forma ilegal después de
la renuncia del ex presidente evo
morales en un caso conocido como golpe
de estado 2 la sentencia fue emitida por
el tribunal primero de sentencia de la
ciudad de la paz años fue acusada de
incumplimiento de deberes y de tomar
resoluciones contrarias a la
constitución de bolivia este juicio
escandaloso mediático y demorado es tal
vez el más reciente capítulo de la
crisis y de la división política que hay
en bolivia varios sectores critican que
los líderes del país han usado los
tribunales para afectar a sus
adversarios políticos la condena en sí
misma también ha sido señalada de ser
una muestra más de la crisis o del
declive de los valores democráticos que
viven no solamente bolivia sino también
otros países de la región sobre su
condena se pronunció precisamente la ex
presidenta ya nine años escuchemos
mi gente
sabe que esos delitos por lo que me
están acusando
no nos he cometido
bolivia entera
sabe que fue una
consecuencia de todo lo que sucedió en
el 2019
porque aquel que cometió un fraude
electoral
aquel que cometió
incumplimiento a la constitución y
respetando hacia un referéndum
establecido en la constitución política
del citado
está feliz y libre haciendo política en
la calle
esta sentencia es apelable una opción
que la defensa de agnès ya advirtió que
aprovechara para buscar una nulidad del
caso por falta de garantías por
irregularidades y también por falta de
derechos una apelación que será ante
instancias bolivianas pero la defensa no
descarta llegar también a esferas
internacionales desde la otra orilla el
oficialismo indicó que también apelará
la sentencia para que ésta sea extendida
a 15 años de prisión el ex presidente
evo morales se refirió precisamente a la
condena de años escuchemos
pese a las mentiras chicanas e incluso
actuaciones para decir que estaba
enferma oa punto de morir la justicia
sentenció que áñez y sus cómplices
asaltaron el poder con un golpe de
estado diez años de cárcel es una pena
benigna en relación al daño que causaron
a la democracia
diferentes analistas bolivianos también
analistas extranjeros citados por
diferentes medios locales y medios
internacionales han puesto en entredicho
la institucionalidad de este país
suramericano hay quienes dicen que el
tribunal tenía motivaciones políticas
otros indican que simplemente ha sido
garante de la ley boliviana lo que sí es
cierto es que deja ver las divisiones
que tiene este país deja ver que la
crisis política del 2019 sigue siendo
una herida abierta en la política y en
la democracia boliviana podrá entonces
cerrarse está herida es este juicio
realizado en la justicia ordinaria el
procedimiento tal y como lo indica la
ley para este tipo de casos en
específico cuando estamos hablando de
una ex mandataria del país en su intento
de apelación años tendrá garantías la
apelación del oficialismo el oficialismo
afirmó pues que va a apelar esto se
llevará a cabo para que sean extendidas
apenas a 15 años ya se los estaba
explicando es esto viable está la
justicia boliviana cooptada por el más
que es el partido oficialista hay
garantías de separación de poderes e
institucionalidad bolivia es nuestro
foco de análisis la condena ya ni idea
es persecución o justicia es en nuestro
tema de análisis y debate hoy en nuestro
programa y para conversar sobre este
tema saludamos a luciana jáuregui ella
es socióloga es también doctora en
ciencias políticas y sociales de la unam
es también investigadora y docente
universitaria se encuentra en la ciudad
de cochabamba en bolivia en esa misma
ciudad también se encuentra nuestro
invitado en el son nogales él es doctor
en ciencias sociales por flacso ecuador
es también docente de las universidades
de ecuador y de la universidad central
de cochabamba ustedes nuestros
televidentes también hacen parte de esta
conversación estamos en las diferentes
redes sociales ya ustedes lo saben no se
encuentran en facebook en instagram en
twitter también nos encuentran y pueden
ver nuestra señal en streaming en vivo a
través de youtube nos encuentran como
24s santi logo que es mi cuenta personal
nuestra etiqueta para que usted deje
todos sus comentarios es numeral del
debate efe 24 esperamos entonces sus
comentarios y preguntas relacionadas con
el tema que vamos a analizar en el día
de hoy le dé la bienvenida entonces a
luciana la ciudad de cochabamba luciana
gracias por acompañarnos hoy en el
programa y nuestra pregunta como punto
de partida para el análisis y para el
debate su opinión sobre esta sentencia
dictada por este tribunal de la ciudad
de la paz diez años de prisión para la
ex presidenta interina jan ideales cuál
es su opinión
gracias ampliado por la invitación vamos
a estar con ustedes la verdad es que se
trata de una sentencia tiene un efecto
histórico no tanto como para la
interpretación de los hechos pasados de
la crisis de 2019 como también para la
forma en que se van a desenvolver las
fuerzas políticas sin embargo quizás ahí
la gran paradoja es que a pesar de la de
la contundencia y las implicancias
políticas jurídicas etcétera de la
sentencia en este momento me da la
impresión que no han tenido los efectos
políticos esperados es decir que ha
pasado casi como un evento con poca
capacidad de interpelación y de
movilización en la que las fuerzas
políticas han mostrado las posiciones
más radicales sin que esto no
necesariamente haya interpelado a la
población en general con todo de la
sentencia de un 'smartphone' precedente
sobre todo en los procesos judiciales
que se vienen a posteriori para ver cómo
se van a tramitar el caso golpe 1 golpe
traidor de 4 golpe 5 que son una serie
de casos en los que sin duda esta
primera ascendencia marca un precedente
fundamental y por supuesto tiene que ver
también con la forma en que
esta sentencia va a generar a
lineamientos políticos en una oposición
dispersa y también en una en un
oficialismo que igualmente está tratando
de encontrar bien significación sí y
también ahora le doy la bienvenida a
nelson nogales también se encuentra en
la ciudad de cochabamba nelson
bienvenido al programa también gracias
por acompañarnos punto de partida
opinión sobre esta sentencia cuál es su
perspectiva
cómo estás santiago muchas gracias por
la invitación al igual que luciana yo
pienso que si este resultado o digo esta
condena marca un precedente para
para futuros juicios ya
miembros del oficialismo ya salieron a
mencionar de que tiene año se le va a
procesar por genocidio y
responsabilizando la de las masacres de
senkata y de sacaba y otros procesos más
lo mismo los familiares de las víctimas
de estos eventos entonces también
adelantaron que van a continuar juicios
lógicamente pues este juicio tiene
varios vistos de alguna manera de
nulidad de algunos sensores que incluso
ya los mencionó el relator de las
naciones unidas para la justicia que
estuvo aquí hace algunos meses atrás
pero al margen de ello si tiene unos
efectos en la política
interna ya que van a modificar la
correlación de fuerzas ya esté la
oposición de alguna manera armar a una
serie de estrategias políticas para
tratar de movilizar y evitar
quizás juicios también contra los
líderes en líderes cívicos
encabezaron lógicamente las
movilizaciones en el 2019
nelson continuó con usted para hacer la
ronda a la inversa ya le doy la palabra
a luciana voy al punto de partida pero
el punto de partida no está debate sino
de esta situación que estamos analizando
en bolivia y es si fue o no
constitucional ese ascenso de áñez
en el momento en el que había una
especie de vacío de poder en bolivia a
raíz de esta crisis que comenzó en ese
país ella como presidenta interina tenía
que gobernar estabilizar el país y
convocar a elecciones unas elecciones en
las que precisamente ganó el actual
presidente luís arce
era constitucional o no este ascenso a
nelson
hay que considerar varios elementos en
realidad esto es muy complejo de definir
primero hay que considerar que los
presidentes de las respectivas cámaras
que eran del partido oficialista adriana
salvatierra y otros renunciaron o sea es
más renunciaron por instructiva de
líderes del partido para dejar una
ausencia de poder entonces había un
vacío de poder que de alguna manera se
tenía que llenar ahora los miembros
legislativos legisladores del más no
asistieron a las
bueno a las reuniones del congreso por
lo tanto lógicamente el coro de alguna
manera pues no era el suficiente pero se
vio se dio como una sucesión
constitucional
dada digamos la ausencia de poder esto
tiene múltiples interpretaciones
desde la constitucionalidad digamos
desde sus efectos políticos desde sus
efectos jurídicos dado que si se declara
inconstitucional este gobierno
implicaría que todos sus actos incluso
las elecciones en las que ganó
nuevamente el más con luís arce serían
de nulo y serían nulas entonces todos
los actos de ese gobierno y los
consecuentes serían nulos y eso lleva a
un gran problema o sea cómo resolvemos
este entrampado si es que se declara
nulo ese gobierno y si se vuelve una
espiral que pues no tiene no tiene fin y
se empiezan a encontrar más más cabos y
más aristas a este problema luciana su
opinión también para este punto de
partida de la situación fue constituir
este ascenso de años en el poder
yo quisiera previamente hacer una
aclaración porque la sentencia que se
acaba de producir en realidad tienen que
ver con juzgar a arias en su condición
de senadora es decir previa a que ella
asuma funciones presidenciales esto
quiere decir que lo que está en juego en
realidad en esta sentencia es la
autoproclamación de jeanine áñez la
vulneración de las normas de sucesión
que se produjeron durante la crisis
política en 2019 porque recordemos que
años no era ni presidenta del senado ni
presidenta de la cámara de diputados y
que en todo caso había un procedimiento
tanto en la constitución política del
estado como dentro de los reglamentos de
debates de la cámara de senadores como
de diputados que sin nada que
necesariamente en los procesos de
sucesión constitucional debían pasar por
la asamblea legislativa plurinacional
evidentemente el escenario político en
ese momento era profundamente adverso no
sobre todo porque se trataba de una
disputa precisamente en torno al sentido
de la democracia entre algunos que
defendían y que estaban en contra de la
repostulación de evo morales la denuncia
de fraude electoral
posteriormente de otro bloque que
defendía más bien una noción de justicia
más vinculada a la equidad y la justicia
social en todo caso en ese escenario
convulso evidentemente también también
había un proceso de desestructuración
del propio más lo que impidió además de
los demás de amedrentamiento etcétera
que él más pudiera en sus liderazgos más
altos converger en la asamblea
legislativa plurinacional
pero eso no quiere decir que haya
motivos suficientes para que la
presidenta años inclusive en el mismo de
lunes y martes que son los dos días que
se juzgan en esta sentencia empieza a
tomar atribuciones presidenciales que
tienen que ver con la armanda todas las
personas armadas ocupar
oficinas públicas que correspondían por
ejemplo adrián a salvatierra
disponer de los bienes del estado como
aviones etcétera previo incluso a que
aquella misma curar en él como
presidenta no en todo caso yo creo que
ahí va a aybar los indicios que
polemizan completamente la
legitimidad y legalidad del gobierno de
años no yo creo que parte de la
sentencia ha sido justamente evidencia
que se han vulnerado varios procesos de
la constitución y varios reglamentos
también como le mencionado si importante
esa aclaración que hace luciana al
inicio de esta intervención luciana
continúa con usted también para hacer la
ronda a la inversa me preocupa mucho y
tal vez lo que uno ve fuera de las
fronteras bolivianas es el estado de la
justicia de este país y se puede confiar
en la institucionalidad de este país
luciana hay separación de poderes allí
está el partido de turno o el gobierno
de turno tratando de cooptar de cierta
forma el poder judicial
su beneficio y también para generar esta
suerte de revanchas políticas que no
solamente se están viendo en bolivia
sino que también se están viendo en
otros países de américa latina'
yo creo que si os evidentemente en este
momento estamos en un escenario de
crisis institucional profunda y
específicamente en relación al poder
judicial y esto no tiene que ver
solamente con el partido de gobierno
sino que durante el propio mandato de
anne se evidenció cómo la justicia era
maleable según la correlación de fuerzas
jurídicas entonces sin duda no se pueden
negar que existen interferencias
políticas
de uno y otro bando para presionar
intervenir en relación a los procesos
judiciales que se llevan a cabo sobre
sin negada pero al mismo tiempo creo que
sí es importante palpar la coyuntura
política que vivimos actualmente
no es menos llamativo que la sentencia
que se haya producido o que se ha
producido contra años no haya generado
en un contexto de profundo
cuestionamiento a las instituciones
ningún tipo de interpelación en
utilización ciudadana no suele esto
quiere decir que aunque la población
desconfía profundamente de los
procedimientos judiciales etcétera sin
embargo hay una cierta aceptación o por
lo menos un cierto distanciamiento
de las residentas no no es menor que y
sobre todo quiero enfatizar en esto que
la sentencia contra años haya develado
más bien la propia debilidad de las
fuerzas políticas de oposición que no
han logrado ni siquiera articularse ni
convocar una movilización ciudadana que
rememoró
su épica del 2019 si nelson su opinión
sobre sobre este tema y sobre estos
puntos que expresa a luciana esto no ha
generado ningún tipo de convulsión
social digámoslo así que son escenarios
que ya nos estamos acostumbrando en
bolivia cualquier decisión cualquier
movimiento político tanto del mazo de la
oposición generaba un gran malestar
entre la ciudadanía esto parece que ha
pasado y la gente simplemente lo ha
aceptado
bueno yo creo que habría que considerar
algunos factores uno de ellos es que la
gente dado dado el contexto del comité y
todo eso tiene que digamos como unas
preocupaciones primarias desea es tratar
de resolver sus condiciones materiales y
de subsistencia pues la economía fue
golpeada por el kobe pero yo creo otro
factor muy relevante es digamos la
ausencia de unos liderazgos o sea ella
prácticamente digamos el momento de los
caudillos ha pasado y más bien las los
líderes cívicos que en ese entonces
lideraron todas las revueltas ahora
están ocupando cargos públicos ya sea
como alcaldes ya sea como gobernadores
por lo tanto pues ellos también tienen
otras preocupaciones y seguramente no se
quieren al venir con el gobierno dado y
ha apuntado las correlaciones después
entonces están como el estático güey
como en una constante en negociación y
en un constante
digamos
y paralización de digamos de las fuerzas
entonces ellos también tienen las
preocupaciones del cob y de la crisis
económica y otros y por parte de la
población yo creo que hay que mencionar
la resignación porque prácticamente la
justicia se ha debilitado mucho en los
últimos años y no estamos hablando
solamente de la intervención del mar
sino anteriormente ya la justicia era
muy permeable a la influencia política
del gobierno o de algunos partidos pero
en los últimos años se ha vuelto mucho
más porque ya es permeable la influencia
económica la influencia política
desde la elección de los jueces por
igual y claro desde elección de los
jueces por votación entonces eso hace
que lógicamente la justicia
y esté sujeta como a unas relaciones
clientelares y que los jueces no sean de
carrera prácticamente menos del 50 por
ciento de jueces son son de carreras los
fiscales lo mismo son elegidos por voto
y claro quienes movilizan los votos son
aquellos que tienen digamos como algunas
empresas electorales o algunos grupos ya
organizados que generalmente son los
partidos políticos si entonces dadas
esas circunstancias es muy difícil
hablar de la independencia judicial
nelson entonces con ese con ese panorama
que no hay unas garantías de
independencia una ciudadanía que en
cierta forma también ya está resignada
cansada también de esta inestabilidad
política una oposición que está no viven
articulada que no logra tener un poder
de convocatoria muy grande y el
oficialismo entonces dónde queda
retomando este término que había puesto
allí sobre la mesa de las revanchas
políticas que tanta motivación política
tuvo entonces este fallo entendiendo
ahora que no hay tantas garantías desde
el poder judicial
en realidad este dado que el partido
oficialista también tiene como unas
rupturas internas a pesar de que ellos
lo niegan constantemente si se puede
identificar algunos bloques y algunos
sirven como triunfadores en cambio otros
ven incluso a través del tweet de evo
morales que ellos querían una sentencia
mucho más mucho mayor pero que claro
depende mucho del bloque de
del partido oficialista digamos las
lecturas que tienen con respecto a esta
sentencia digamos los futuros procesos
pero el oficialismo justamente en ese
desgaste de de pugnas internas tampoco
tiene un norte o digamos una una agenda
para continuar digamos una
una revancha política de un corto de un
largo alcance entonces gran parte de las
decisiones del gobierno se dan digamos
sobre la marcha y por las presiones
internas del mazo sea recordemos que
revisarse no es que tenga una base
militante la base militante responde
generalmente a evo morales o a
choquehuanca y en esa digamos orfandad
de de bases pues el presidente y digamos
en los poderes están sujetos como a
presiones de estos otros bloques de
entrar dentro del partido oficialista
luciana regresó con usted usted
mencionaba y nos hacía la aclaración que
la expresidenta áñez ha sido juzgada y
este fallo es retomando algunos casos de
cuando ella era senadora pero algunos de
los reclamos que hace la defensa es
justamente que haya sido juzgada dentro
del marco de una justicia ordinaria
porque al haber sido presidenta de
bolivia debía haber sido
llevado a este proceso judicial en otro
marco legislativo
como entender entonces esas diferencias
ahí o si yo estoy equivocado entonces
aclárenos dentro del marco legal
boliviano del cual no conozco a
profundidad si es que estamos
entendiendo mal este punto de vista de
la defensa como fue realizado este este
juicio en el marco de la justicia
ordinaria y no se estaba juzgando como
una expresidenta
yo creo que justamente eso es parte de
la disputa política porque desde el lado
de la defensa se alega que ya ni
añadiría ser juzgada a través de un
juicio de responsabilidades mientras que
del otro lado se respalda también en la
normativa de que los parlamentarios es
decir en su condición de senadora no
gozan de inmunidad en la justicia y que
por lo tanto giannina les debería ser
juzgada por la vida ordinaria esto tiene
que ver también con los los los juicios
que se vienen a posteriori no que como
les decía unos ya tienen que ver con el
momento en que ya nine años asumió la
presidencia no como por ejemplo son los
casos de la masacre de sacaba de senkata
y que ahí sí habrá que ver si va a
alcanzar el consenso político suficiente
para que ya nine años sea juzgada en un
juicio de responsabilidades en algún
momento las fuerzas de oposición como
comunidad ciudadana se abrieron a esta
posibilidad
pero en este momento yo creo que hay
nuevamente un alineamiento y un
distanciamiento entre las fuerzas
políticas principales para llegar a un
consenso mayor más en todo caso yo creo
que parte de la forma en que se procesa
jeanine áñez es parte de la disputa
política ya sea por el desdoblamiento de
casos es decir que es justamente lo que
la oposición interpela no que janine xxi
el juicio y también que se lleve en
varios tipos penales cuando en realidad
lo que está sucediendo es que
actualmente se está tratando de hacer un
concurso de las diferentes penas que
ella mini anís va a atravesar el
de aquí en adelante
en ese orden de ideas luciana una
apelación eso ya lo anunció la defensa
de la ex presidenta interina que van a
apelar esta sentencia lo pueden hacer
han dicho que lo van a hacer ante las
instancias bolivianas ante qué
instancias puede ser
dado el caso que allí en las instancias
bolivianas no pueda obtener el resultado
que ellos esperan a que instancias
internacionales pueden llegar
bueno para empezar hay que señalar que
la sentencia todavía no ha salido de
modo completo es decir de momento sólo
tenemos la resolución final se espera
que hasta el miércoles se pueda conocer
la sentencia en un sentido más integral
y desde entonces la defensa de yanina
años pueda buscar estrategias
alternativas básicamente tiene tres
alternativas o cuatro si consideramos la
vida internacional no una es apelar y
otra es un procedimiento que se denomina
de casación y otro es un procedimiento
que va hasta azúcar que tiene que ver
con la revisión de la sentencia no al
mismo tiempo la hija de terminales que
en realidad se ha constituido en la
verdadera defensora de de años antes que
la oposición misma ha advertido que va a
acudir precisamente a instancias
internacionales pero de momento no se ve
que esto pueda tener mayores resultados
a mis vecinos también términos políticos
melson y con esta posibilidad de la
apelación y con esta erosión que hay del
poder judicial hay en bolivia que
garantías entonces puede tener la
defensa
es muy probable que se recurra a todas
esas instancias pero que el fallo sea
negativo y que más bien se ratifica la
sentencia o sea lo que se esperaría es
que digamos en tribunales
internacionales hagan una lectura
totalmente distinta y de que a través de
un dictamen
vinculatorio pues se
anulen en el fallo la sentencia si de
otra forma dentro del sistema judicial
boliviano uno puede apelar a todas las
instancias pertinentes y necesarias pero
el fallo vendría a ser lo mismo o sea es
llamativo que este juicio que debió
haber sido por por responsabilidades fue
por vía ordinaria y tuvo un solo un
plazo de diez meses o sea en realidad
duró apenas diez meses lo que demuestra
de que si hubo una presión y digamos un
aceleramiento para que el proceso
concluya lo más pronto posible algo que
en otros procesos y otros juicios
relativos a corrupción que involucran a
miembros del gobierno no ocurre siguen
en la etapa nativa ya han pasado digamos
como años años que es ese tipo de
impunidad digámoslo así es algo
prácticamente común en las justicias en
el resto de américa latina no es
solamente el caso boliviano lo vemos en
otros países donde los procesos
judiciales no avanzan sobre todo cuando
comprometen a figuras políticas
destacadas de los escenarios de cada uno
de los países paso a preguntarles ahora
por la otra cara de la moneda y es el
oficialismo que ha dicho que esta
condena esta sentencia no es suficiente
y quiere apelar para que haya una
extensión para que ésta sea llevada o
elevada hasta los 15 años en ese orden
de ideas y con todo lo que ustedes nos
han explicado de los problemas que hay
con la justicia boliviana
logrará entonces el más cumplir con ese
deseo de extender esa condena a los 15
años luciana
creo que en este momento no hay una
fuerza oficialista que pueda operar de
modo unificado no algo ya señalaba
nelson actualmente estamos en un momento
de transición y de reconfiguración de
los consensos y biológicos y los
alineamientos políticos no y esto
también es parte de la propia
recomposición interna del mar en el que
se pueden advertir al menos tres
tendencias no una vinculada a hace más
asociada a la burocracia una vinculada
huanca más asociada a un movimiento
indígena aimara y otras sociedades
morales que tiene una base más bien
cocalera entonces todas estas facciones
están actualmente en un proceso de
detenciones de disputas en miras a lo
que va a ser el proceso electoral
presidencial siguiente no de momento
inclusive pese a que esta sentencia de
algún modo vuelve a generar
modificaciones y articulaciones y aún
así empiezan a emerger tensiones
internas en la que por ejemplo la más
grata el más espera precisamente apelar
a la misma sentencia y aumentar a 15
años
de prisión y al mismo tiempo habilitar
los procesos judiciales a otros líderes
políticos de la oposición que han
participado también abiertamente en este
proceso como luís fernando que marcó
carlos meza etcétera más y quizás yo
creo que él en términos políticos lo que
se está jugando precisamente es si el
cielo al mar le va a alcanzar su
cohesión interna y fuerza política para
llevar a cabo estos procesos judiciales
a líderes políticos que se encuentran
actualmente en un puesto de poder
político no como decía con él son
gobernadores alcaldes etcétera y si de
ser así también habría que ver si la
propia oposición va a lograr con
gestionarse y articularse y sobre todo
generar un discurso capaz de interpelar
nuevamente a los sujetos que les habían
acompañado durante las políticas
como estamos lo que se puede advertir es
justamente que hay una disonancia entre
la agenda política del oficialismo y la
oposición y la agenda política de la
gente salientes del oficialismo están
lidiando con sus tensiones internas y la
oposición está tratando de recuperar la
ética del 2019 la gente en realidad está
más interesada en la normalización de su
vida cotidiana claro nelson su opinión
sobre este tema sobre ese intento del
gobierno del oficialismo de intentar
extender esta condena y también ese plan
que tienen ahí 10 políticos que están
próximos a ser enjuiciados ya luciana
mencionaba algunos si no estoy mal hay
dos ex presidentes también que están
próximos a entrar en
otro de los casos incluso está un ex
gobernador del departamento de santa
cruz son varias figuras importantes para
la escena regional política boliviana
esto trascender a avanzar a consolidar a
entonces el más su poder sobre la
justicia boliviana
el poder es evidente sea en realidad
sigue ahí como una injerencia ahora
esto de alguna manera está sujeto
digamos como unas negociaciones
llegamos por debajo de la mesa que van a
tener digamos el gobierno evo morales y
los otros líderes se halla estas
negociaciones se vieron durante las
elecciones cuando habilitaron digamos a
algunas ex figuras políticas como
manfred reyes villa que pues era como
una figura que tenía procesos que tenía
sí sobre todo procesos y que de alguna
manera su candidatura
era vista de nulidad por varias razones
pero lo habilitaron como
como candidato y ganó la alcaldía ahora
él está gozando entonces yo creo que si
existe la posibilidad de que se inicie
digamos como el intento de procesar a
todas estas autoridades habría que ver
justamente las figuras legales con las
cuales van a para ser acusados se está
hablando de sedición de terrorismo
y otras entonces yo creo que mucho va a
depender de las negociaciones que puedan
llegar en términos políticos para
digamos frenar o para avanzar en estos
en estos procesos judiciales además de
que también lo que menciona lucían hay
que ver digamos la fortaleza que va a
tener la capacidad de unificación que
pueda tener el gobierno para lógicamente
incrementar como parte de la agenda este
estos procesos
judiciales quiero dejar un poco de lado
este tema de este caso de la
expresidenta áñez porque se me queda en
la mente me queda sonando la palabra que
utilizó luciana una disonancia entre el
oficialismo la oposición y la ciudadanía
el pueblo boliviano y eso me lleva a
preguntarle luciana por el estado de la
democracia y de la institucionalidad
boliviana a raíz de lo sucedido en el
2019 que hubo un punto de quiebre en la
historia política del país ha sido un
capítulo
difícil para bolivia lograr superarlo y
reconstruirse otra vez como nación a
partir de esa fractura que hubo cómo
está ese proceso ha avanzado está
bolivia todavía en riesgo de que la
democracia se caiga por el abismo
digámoslo así o bolivia está saliendo
poco a poco adelante en la
reconstrucción de su democracia a raíz
de lo del 2019
yo creo que en realidad las elecciones
general del 2020 y las son nacionales
del 2021 andan en una forma
cerrado las posibilidades políticas de
que haya un nuevo escenario de ya sea de
vulneración de la constitución a veces
desestabilice de la estabilización
política no es decisión cerrada una
coyuntura crítica
pero eso no quiere decir que haya
desafíos muy importantes en este momento
no uno tiene que ver por supuesto con
esta reestructuración institucional que
mencionábamos porque en este momento
atravesamos una crítica transversal a
todas las fuerzas políticas a todos los
niveles estatales tanto nacionales
departamentales locales porque se trata
de denuncias de corrupción de
ineficiencia sobre todo tienen que ver
con la justicia y realmente han afectado
tanto a las fuerzas de oposición como el
oficialismo entonces en este momento la
ciudadanía está precisamente demandando
que las instituciones justo funcionen
que la justicia funcione
y sobre todo yo creo que lo que es lo
que ha pasado es en cierto modo un
acortamiento de la gente con la
polarización política no es decir en
este momento la polarización ya no le da
réditos a nadie ya no moviliza a nadie
en regular la gente se ha cansado de una
sobre ideologización de la crisis
política y se ha agotado y en realidad a
mí me da la impresión que te sienten
completamente
cansadas de un cierto tipo de discurso
polarizantes de ciertos liderazgos
contenciosos no más gay me dan yo creo
que la ciudadanía en este momento lo que
busca recuperar la estabilidad política
y económica de antes no es decir no
tiene que ver en cierto modo también
porque ganó en el gobierno de hace no
ser el gobierno de arte precisamente y
más en el último tiempo que se ha
fortalecido su liderazgo ha tenido la
capacidad de mostrar senos al menos en
los últimos meses distante de esta
polarización el propio hogar se empezó a
marcar sus diferencias nuevo morales
etcétera y eso creo que ha potenciado su
capital
en todo caso lo que yo creo que una de
los primeros desafíos de su gobierno
actualmente es recuperar la legitimidad
de las instituciones en todos los
niveles dijeron que gran parte de las
políticas del futuro pasan por ahí si
iago esta pregunta porque este es un
problema que no solamente se está viendo
en bolivia de acuerdo a the booking
institución esta investigación que han
publicado ellos recientemente han
mostrado diferentes tipos de erosión
democrática por decirlo así no solamente
en bolivia a raíz de lo del 2019 sino
que también en otros países como el
salvador haití honduras guatemala
paraguay la república dominicana y
nicaragua
es algo que no solamente se está viendo
hoy en suramérica sino que es algo que
se está volviendo común en cierta forma
para varios países de la región su
perspectiva sobre este tema nelson sobre
esta reconstrucción de la democracia
boliviana y de la institucionalidad a
raíz de los hechos del 2019
a ver yo creo que una tarea fundamental
es la recuperación del estado de derecho
y para ello es necesario impulsar la
reforma del sistema judicial porque sin
este pilar que es fundamental para la
protección y el aseguramiento de
libertades y derechos
prácticamente si la democracia va a
estar coja
en el futuro o sea si es necesario
digamos recuperar la justicia de manera
imparcial para que derechos y libertades
en términos políticos sociales
económicos se recupere
prácticamente no basta con que haya unas
elecciones con una una transparencia
digamos más o menos limitada que hay una
participación se trata en realidad si se
necesita como reconstituirse fortalecer
las instituciones bolivianas
principalmente la justicia sin ello es
muy poco lo que se puede hacer respecto
a las otras instituciones porque como ya
dije anteriormente son fáciles de
permear a la injerencia política pero
sobre todo a la influencia económica y
digamos al tri negro planta me queda un
minuto para finalizar el programa quiero
que hagamos la conclusión de lo que va a
suceder con todo este caso y el panorama
político de lo que se viene tal vez para
las próximas semanas muy puntual por
favor luciana su conclusión
yo creo que estamos en un momento de
transición como decía que tiene que ver
con
las fuerzas políticas logre recuperar su
capacidad de iniciativa y logren
cuestionarse no sin duda la sentencia de
agnès enmarca un escenario para luchas
sucesivas en las que socialmente está en
juego y la posición va a tener la
capacidad política de mostrarse de
utilizar el relato que sobre la
democracia la defensa de la democracia
que había permitiéndonos luciana y
nelson su conclusión rápidamente por
favor 30 segundos puedo que de aquí en
adelante las fuerzas políticas van a
tener van a entrar en un sistema de
contención y de negociación constante
para lógicamente resolver este problema
o los futuros procesos judiciales bueno
pues les agradezco a nelson nogales ya
luciana jáuregui muchas gracias por
haber estado con nosotros por su
análisis para la audiencia de france 24
en américa latina ustedes pueden seguir
dejando todas sus preguntas y
comentarios a través de las redes
sociales sigan con nuestra programación
[Música]